this is really looking for watch all the
videos that we've got and we've managed
to piece together by looking at building
the angles up there and stuff we think
we know all right so that's what we're
doing now is that we're looking for if
you remember in the first campaign of
China release 50,000 pounds it was a
picture of a little girl her name is
Anand yeah so we are able to count that
was a year ago and snowing here what
they're doing now all the Waseem what
seem give us an update yeah so basically
what we do is we just ask the locals
we're trying to find that specific girl
and see and see what how she's doing it
so what was happening ok so there's
there's thousands and thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people they are here and when we last
came everything was covered in snow when
it's covered in snow it all looks the
same here so it's hard to find exactly
where she was where it was but we've got
four or five of the locals together
we've watched all the videos that we've
got and we've managed to piece together
by looking at building angles that there
and stuff we think we know where the ABS
okay we're gonna go and check okay we're
gonna go follow each other and hopefully
we'll find her and see how she's doing
with your support and help so basically
where we was given the food
distributions they told us that the girl
that we're looking for in sha allah and
his documentaries about her is in
another place so as you see we're going
through kind of mountains you can say
from a few neighborhoods inshaallah to
find her and when we arrived insha'Allah
we're gonna start searching for her and
findings and inshallah see how she's
doing
and how she's keeping each other so
it was winter it was snowing that's what
you can see from the picture it was very
snowy but last place we use app they
told us to come here because from the
background they said she's around this
area so I think they're known she's
known to the local we're gonna go and
find out that it's very interesting
because you see with a lot of charity
not with a lot of charity I'm glad all
charged the beautiful work but you know
sometimes pictures just taken and you
know and it's just used and it that
pictures doesn't belong to that specific
place but it's very profound and very
extraordinary that you know where the
works that being done you can see for
yourself these are real people and we're
gonna see for ourselves
this picture was taken last year in the
winter so we're gonna go and find her
and see how she is you know she's very
cheerful very happy and inshallah she
has a smile on her face thanks to you
guys ma'sha'allah and why why why do we
want to find it wanna see how she's
doing and to carry on this is really
looking for
[Applause]
masha'Allah masha'Allah translator
hey come off
[Music]
[Music]
let's go let's go we came all the way
here not that she was lost oh he was
kind of looking for her but the fact
that we just wanted to see how she's
doing I'm sorry in the pictures
absolutely totally different we need to
see a picture and see her life is
totally different because when I saw the
picture I saw the video it was profound
and seeing in real life and seeing how
she's doing and she did amazing me on
the best inshaallah
and the fact that we came over here and
she gave me the message and thank you
every single one of you guys his worth
that trip is worth that trip is worth
that time and may Allah bless you guys
carry on each other hoping these people
I can't believe that we've actually
found that seriously when I took that
picture months and months ago I came out
here this place was covered with slow I
didn't even know what it's called when
we took that one picture after one child
and people's hearts reacted to it people
wanted to know more about who this child
is and I told him there's tens hundreds
of thousands of refugees living here how
am I meant to go back and find this one
girl that we took a picture of luckily I
spoke to her enough to remember her name
and a few other details about her like
we tried to do with every child are we
that we speak to and I really to be
honest had no faith and that would
actually find it and now that we have I
know it means so much to these guys and
for everybody that was asking about her
as well inshallah you can continue our
work repair her family and everybody
else here
I want each